[Music]
we are not an army so our strategy must
be stealth
it's an alchemical strategy and what do
i mean by stealth i mean
the house
of
constipated reason
must be
infiltrated
by art
by dreamers
by vision
and
what is new
is
that there are massive technologies
available to us
not available in the 60s they were not
designed for us they were not intended
for us it was never ever thought
that such power should flow into the
hands of freaks such as ourselves
nevertheless
through the perverse nature of the
unfolding of the world
we have such tools and i'm referring as
you probably anticipate the internet
no
gay kid in montana
no chinese scholar in botswana
no person anywhere with a specialized
interest or predilection now need feel
alone
there is no
aloneness you can find your people find
the others
and then you will know what to do well
now you can find
the others you don't have to stick a
flower in your hair and go to san
francisco
you just to go to the web
find the others
we all need to create affinity groups
which are subsets of the much larger
community that we're part of
and then
using this technology which was designed
to keep track of us to pick our pockets
and to sell us junk we don't want
use this technology to produce
art massive amounts
of subversive art
there's a wonderful english poet and
writer rudyard kipling and he wrote a
children's short story called the cat
who walked by himself
and it's a story of how the dog came to
the cave of man
and would lay at the man's feet but the
cat would never come and when the woman
asked the cat why it would never come
and said
i am the cat who walks by himself
and all places are alike to me
and i think transcending our cultures is
going to be extraordinarily necessary
for our survival
well how do you shed your culture how do
you transcend your culture by digging
into your soul
with the tools
that have been given you to make art
this is how cultures are transformed
by art which flows up and actually
submerges the previous cultural forms
there is an
obligation to produce
the new
i mean this is what you are you are some
kind of a mystery
suspended
between two eternities
and in that moment
when a mind looks out at a world
and asks the question what is it
in that moment
art can be created and it is the only
form of immortality that i have any
certainty of and it's available to
everyone
[Music]
you